unaccompanied minors seeking asylum in
this country that have been housed in
hotels and have gone missing well a
little earlier I spoke to Dame Sarah
Thornton who spent 30 years in the
police and she was Chief Constable of
Thames Valley she was also appointed by
Theresa May to be the independent
anti-slavery commissioner I started by
asking her what had happened
well we know that organized crime groups
will Target vulnerable children an
unaccompanied Asylum seeking children
are vulnerable they're separated from
their families they may have been
traumatized I think it's clear that the
traffickers and the exploiters have been
targeting them they know where they are
in the hotels and they're preying on
these children and my my real fear is
that the boys will be locked in cannabis
Farms they may be
um involved in county lines drug
distribution and the girls May well end
up in the sex industry so there's a real
concern about the risk
of these uh children and young people
you know to talk about the numbers
involved here almost 200 and you're
talking about the organized crime that
they may be falling into
I just find it astonishing it's
staggering how is this only coming to
light now
so in fact I think there are 440 that
have been reported missing of who 200
are still unaccounted for that's the
real concern but it does seem to me that
government have been given warnings
about this which they appear to have
failed to heat I mean back in the summer
last year in 2022 the home Affairs
committee said the placement of children
in these hotels which is unlawful needed
to stop
the independent Chief Inspector of
borders immigration also Rose the issue
back in October he said the hotels are
fine as a crisis response but it become
a core response and it needed to stop
and then the children's charity epap
made a report last year when there were
45 missing children now there are 440 so
the situation has escalated children
mustn't be placed in these hotels they
need to be properly supported by local
authorities and the local authorities
need to be funded in order to do so
so actually the answer to my question
why is this only coming to light now is
even more depressing it has been known
for some time but actually the reality
is that no action has been taken who
does the buck stop it's just got worse
and worse
who just the butt stop with who do you
blame
well the
issue is partly caused by the number of
uh people coming across the channel in
small boats and that clearly overwhelmed
uh Kent County Council and they said to
the government we can't continue to
provide the support uh that we should
provide and that's why as an interim
measure there's an emergency measure the
home office uh set up these hotels but
that was 18 months two years ago the law
requires local authorities to protect
and Safeguard children and that's what
needs to happen uh government needs to
work with the local authorities and
needs to make available adequate funding
so they can do it properly these
children are vulnerable they need to be
supported ideally I think in in foster
homes but certainly in Specialist Care
facilities for them
there's a lot of talk in politics about
a so-called hostile environment for
people trying to come to the United
Kingdom do you worry that some of the
impact of that has been I guess that
the system hasn't cared for some of
these miners in the way that it should
have
I think sometimes when you hear people
talk about young galbanian people it's
as if somehow they don't count and
they're not the same as our children you
know the law in this country makes no
differentiation between children on the
basis of their nationality nor indeed
whether they're migrants so an Albanian
child who's 16 years old has all the
rights under the children's act that a
British child would have and I think we
would want to treat children uh in that
way and not differentiating the way that
appears to be happening
um thank you for some really really
powerful words there on this case it's
something that I'm very pleased that
we've been able to highlight on the
program today and if I may I did just
want to talk about the death of Zara
Alina now Zara is the law graduate who
was brutally murdered walking home in a
random attack now it's come to like that
herkello was wrongly assessed as medium
risk and opportunities were missed that
could have saved her life
what states is the probation service
currently in
can I just say that I you know an
absolutely horrific murder and my heart
goes out to the family of friends of
Zara but I was interested when reading
about this case that the Chief Inspector
of probation talked about systemic
issues in the probation service not only
were there substantial delays in the
case being reviewed it was then given to
a newly qualified probation officer who
assessed the cases as medium and then
after he'd been released from prison
um he repeatedly breached his license
conditions and a recall uh was made for
him to be recalled to prison but
unfortunately uh Zara was murdered
before that could happen and I think it
just points out the fact that if we are
going to release people on license uh
before the end of their sentence then we
need a probation service that is
properly equipped and funded and
resourced to ensure that the public can
be publicly inadequately protective
because clearly in this case Zara was
not protected
so do you think that the probation
service isn't being properly funded and
resourced right now
I think that's certainly the case in the
time when I was a police officer there
were reforms of the probation service
which just appeared to reduce its
capacity and capability to do the jobs
that the staff in the organization
wanted to do and this case I've heard
people interviewed from the probation
service who talk about massive caseloads
and how on Earth can a vibration officer
do their job properly if they're being
asked to supervise many many cases and
then when it's not adequately resourced
these awful things happen has happened
to Zara evina yeah that's certainly uh
We've certainly seen the worst possible
consequences of that with her case
there's been a lot of discussion about
culture in the police I just wonder as
someone you know who've obviously been
involved in the police in your time the
commissioner Mark Rowley saying that two
or three met police officers every week
expected to be appearing in court on
criminal charges
is the culture rotten
so I think we've all been horrified by
recent cases
um and it does raise serious questions
about the culture because I think you
can't keep on saying it's just One Bad
Apple it's another Bad Apple I do think
that Sir Mark Rowley has got a huge
Challenge on his hands he needs to be
absolutely fearless and robust in
rooting out those people who should not
be police officers but his challenge of
course is he's got to do that at the
same time as maintaining the morale of
all the decent officers who are
committed to public service and he's
also got to have an eye on thinking
about who we're going to recruit in the
future we want to have a Police Service
which people want to join so they too
can help protect the public and serve
the public
did you witness any of this kind of bad
behavior I guess in your time in the
place
when I was first Constable but that's
nearly 40 years ago there was a casual
sexism I guess I mean women got treated
differently would never ever post to
women in a patrol car together and that
was kind of institutionalized uh things
have moved on a long way and I always
used to say and it's seven years since I
left the Police Service in terms of a
police force
by the time you achieved Constable it
would take a very brave person to be
directly in openly Sexes towards you so
I you know towards the end of my service
it wasn't an issue but for sure 30 40
years ago it was part of the system